welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz we're back with a another
edition of the
15 minutes with a mentor series where we
interview some of the
brilliant mentors we've onboarded and
welcome to the recruitment mentors
community platform
and in this series really simply we're
going to ask some of the mentors
seven questions in 15 minutes to find
out things like how they've overcome
some of their biggest challenges
to what's been the most successful
method for them to continue to win
business i'm really excited to be joined
by liz today
but before i ask liz the first question
liz if you could
introduce yourself for those that may
not know who you are and then we'll
we'll get into it
yep so i'm liz knighthaft and i
own cressida consulting which is a
company that i set up earlier in the
year
we build technical teams for the
engineering and automation sector
and prior to um starting my own business
i worked for the s3 group for
16 years so i joined in 2004 the year
before they floated
and i built huxley engineering in
manchester for about 10 years
on the permanent side and then i went on
to work for two other brands within the
group um
on the contract side as well amazing
i'm excited to get your answers on these
questions liz so the first one
is um so what what's been your biggest
challenge so far this year and
and how have you overcome it
um okay so i'd say the obvious one
is incorporating my company over
christmas
and then a couple of days into the new
year having to homeschool three kids
so that was that was fun um
but aside from that i think the biggest
challenge for me honestly
is that i haven't been a hands-on
recruiter for over 10 years
you know i've been managing teams for a
long long time
and you know it's just happened to go
back to being hands-on when so much
has kind of changed so um yeah i'd say
that's been the biggest challenge for me
really
and then i guess on that how what's
helped you really get to grips with
being back on the tools
out of interest i think um
i think it's recognizing what's changed
and what stayed the same so i think in
some ways there's been drastic changes
because when i
unless i'm really old now but when i was
a hands-on recruiter there was no
linkedin
there was no social media it was just um
selling in over the phone and um
speaking to people by email
and i think now i've realized that you
know you've got to build a personal
brand and it was getting my head around
that
and i've still not overcome that
challenge fully yet but i'm learning and
i've joined two communities the
recruitment mentors being one
required being the other and i'm just
surrounding myself by people who can
bring me up to date with the latest
trends and
you know technologies and but then some
things never change and i think the
power of relationships never change
so i have just i just prioritize
investing in
really good relationships with my
candidates and then that'll that will
pay dividends if i look after them they
look out for me
yeah no i really like the way that you
articulated that sort of recognizing
what's changed and
what what hasn't um so i'm sure you
would have seen plenty of these
linkedin polls we've been pulled to
death with it around the sort of
flexible working piece but i think
everyone everyone wants people's
opinions on this right so i think
recruiters are very well positioned
from the markets that they serve to have
a sort of interesting lens on this topic
so the second question i have for you is
like how do you see the future of work
is it fully remote is it hybrid
is it back to the office or a
combination of all of them
and and why so you can talk about from
the communities that you're speaking to
but also from the lens that
you the market that you support the
conversation you're having about what's
your future work from your point of view
and why
yeah i think you've touched on on
something there
the the crucial bit there was it depends
on the industry
so working in engineering there's gonna
be
times where you have to be in the office
you have to be in a factory you have to
be on site
to watch a build you know that's never
going to change
but what i am finding in that what i'm
finding is that companies that are
going back to their pre-pandemic ways
are going to be missing out i can see
candidates already
looking to move on because they've got
used to working from home a lot more
they don't see the need to go back in
five days a week
and now they're getting an inkling that
these companies are going to um
you know these companies are going to go
back to their old ways
they're like well i don't want that
anymore we've moved on so i definitely
think in engineering at least
that it's gonna be a combination and i
think if you can offer as much
flexibility as possible
whilst having the understanding that
when you need to be in the office you
need to be there
i think those are the companies that are
going to get the best candidates
it's opened up so many possibilities for
companies you know
previously a candidate might have been
too far away but now that
now they can work for them remotely so
it's it's amazing it's transformed the
industry really
yeah that's really interesting and then
my next question is
what so far since starting your business
what's been the most effective way for
you to
to win business so far this year
um the most effective way of winning
business well it's
it's repeat business but how i get that
business in the first place
is it i let the candidates speak for
themselves
it's the strength of my candidates that
gets business so
i invest heavily in building up really
solid relationships with
you know exceptional candidates that
i've had hunted
i then approach companies either over
the phone saying look you know i've got
a candidate that i'd like to talk to you
about
and or i'll do it by email either way
but that's
that's how i do it the the candidate
skills it's the strength of the
candidate skill set that
gets me through the door yeah nice yeah
i love
relationships has come up a lot when
we've asked that question
so it's interesting that you mentioned
that as well um
so what i'd really like to hear from you
uh liz is basically i love asking this
question so i
i want to cast you back to 2004
and i want to ask you what
if you could speak to to liz 2000 in
2004
like you're just embarking on your
criminal recruitment a career that you
can end up
yeah i guess go towards working in for
20 years of your life
like what seventeen houston i'm still
going i said going on to i said going on
to
going to almost but um
what what advice would you give liz if
you could speak to her
back then do you think yeah i got you
know what i got
asked this recently actually and um the
biggest
well there's two things the first one
the biggest one for me is to ask for
help
um i think as a 21 year old in
recruitment
i saw um i saw it as a vulnerability
and i had all these amazing people
around me ready to give me their pills
of wisdom and i was like oh but if i ask
this what if they think i'm
you know i can't do it and actually once
i got over that and started asking for
help and listening to people
and asking you know you're good at this
how'd you do it
listening to calls that's when it really
clicked for me so that is the biggest
thing
for me is to ask for help and i think
second of all
if you're new to an industry or you're
new to recruitment like don't worry if
you're not an expert in your field just
like let the candidates do the talking
so
take it away from yourself and when you
are speaking to potential customers
about
candidates just talk about the candidate
talk about their personality talk about
what they can bring
you don't have to know anything beyond
that so
yeah that's that's the second bit i
would say no
i love that so my next question is a bit
more um
less serious so i want to hear from you
what's the funniest or strangest
candidate excuse you've heard so far in
your career
[Laughter]
oh dear um do you know
i think and engineers i have to say
are just straight up they will say it
how it is and if they don't want an
interview
or they don't want the job they will
tell you having said that
and i have had seen colleagues kind of
with their head in the hands over the
years um
and we've had everything from like you
know my house burning down
to um i can't go to a first stage
interview because i might be pregnant
that was another one
[Laughter]
i love that i just i was just thinking
there's just always funny stories in
there but
yeah um the the net the next question i
have is
it's just a bit more of a scenario
basically and what i'd love to just
hear from you is how you would approach
this scenario which is a common scenario
that recruiters will find themselves
in so the scenario is particularly
business that you've been trying to get
in with for some time
they're a great brand you're confident
that you can help them um
finally buy it might be for you specking
out um a cv
trying to speak to them about a
candidate but the relevant person that
you need to speak to
uh reaches out and you get a call but
tim so that call
is going really well you're building
rapport but when it gets to crunch time
they said look liz it's it's been great
speaking to you really like what you're
doing i'm glad we've had this callback
at the moment
we only work with agencies that are on
our psl
and i just want to sort of hear sort of
how you would sort of navigate
that or approach that conversation
yeah um okay and the person that i'm
speaking to do they are they like a
decision maker
yeah they're a decision maker yeah yeah
um
i think with psl's um i think you've got
to kind of qualify
what you mean by a psl because in some
companies it can just be
you're an approved supplier so once
you've got the term sorted you're ready
to go and you can
crack on building the relationship so in
some ways not a lot
changes but then you get other psls
where and this is what you need to
understand so i'd ask you know
when you say psl what's involved how
many
agencies are on it how many agencies
would you give
a particular job to and you're trying to
understand
what type of structure is it is it some
kind of
faceless entity where you submit cds and
you
you hear back in a couple of weeks and
there's no kind of human contact or
is it one where you can have regular
contact and you can build up a
relationship
and i work exclusively with i'd say 90
of my customers so if there is an
opportunity to work exclusively i'll
always pursue it but
if it's just me versus 20 other agencies
i i
that's not my ideal customer and i would
say to them
pretty much that i would say that i
wouldn't be doing you a service
by um by going into that type of
setup but if you're willing to kind of
consider a two-week exclusivity
period i can really show you what i can
do and i'd give them examples of
other companies that i've helped i'd
also understand what their pain points
are what they've struggled with
and what do they struggle with where do
they typically
get people from what companies do they
like to see people from
and if i think i can help them with the
pain points then i'll say look
this is what i can do for you i can let
you know anytime i had some someone from
that company and
as a minimum i would want to i would
want to leave that call with either a
meeting or another call booked in
but ideally i'd want to just get terms
sorted um or at least agree that i can
call them back
with any candidates that they've said
that they they'd like to see
so probably from that angle but i would
never be afraid
walking away if it's not conducive with
with what
you know how i work and what i'm good at
yeah i think that's a really great point
i think
yes it's i guess the advice there is
yeah don't assume
that you understand what their psl is
obviously it's a common phrase so
one let's make sure you understand that
and then two what questions are you
asking them to understand
what challenges and pain points they
have that you could add value around
yeah
that that's great so final question
is so a real sort of popular area that
a lot of recruiters in inside the
community want um help with is sort of
time management
and prioritization so my last question
is around that so i wanna sort of you
can
use what share what you do now or maybe
what he did when um
he was in a billing role or when he was
working at s3 but
so what what non-negotiable do you live
by each day that you feel
has a sort of real impact on your
productivity and and helps you maximize
each day in recruitment okay so
something i do within my day like my day
plan that
yeah so just something that you live by
basically that you think really has
helped you
remain productive yeah um
the number one thing that i do is no
matter how busy i am
or no matter how many projects i've got
on i will always invest time and head on
to an exceptional
engineers um because the idea is that i
want to get to the point where
when i have somebody call me and say i
need this person i already know who to
recommend
and the person that i recommend is
someone that i've already qualified i've
got
trust with and i want to be able to pass
that trust on to the
to the client so that they don't drop
out they turn up for interview they
don't drop out after six months so
no matter how busy i am it builds in my
network
and it's building my network of
headquartered candidates but
that would be no good in itself i always
make sure that i build my contacts as
well
because there's no point having con um
head hunted candidates if i've got no
one to
go to take them to do you know i mean no
businesses to
take them to um and i remember as a
consultant i would add like 150
contacts a month and you know
it's so important that you can't do this
job if you don't know who you're
actually
approaching um so you know even in the
days of gdpr
you know you've got to be you know
you've got to add the person
as a contact phone them get permission
and really kind of
try to understand what what it is they
they hire so
yeah i'd say that's my non-negotiable
yeah so what what you said there is
you're sort of
because it's i think it's two parts
isn't it it's what i hear from
recruiters a lot is
there's so much going on i'm unsure what
to prioritize
that can help me achieve the results
that i want so
what you're saying there time and time
again throughout your career when you've
prioritized
yeah building relationships getting
while getting contacts
kind of making sure you're always making
time to build your candidate pool
that that's paid dividends so i guess
just the final part to them what
what's your sort of framework or process
to make sure like you said
regardless of how busy i am but i think
the next part then is okay well how do
you
make sure that you do make time for that
what's your sort of framework for that
out of interest
yeah um so on a very okay just
on a simple level in the morning i would
do all my agent
work so that would be interviewing
candidates for
live projects and then speaking to the
companies
um to to speak to them about those
candidates so it's kind of urgent stuff
in the morning
and then in the afternoon it's my more
strategic
business development so it's business
development every afternoon
based on it could be selling in a really
strong candidate that you've got
it could be um selling into some target
companies that you'd really like to
develop and
develop a relationship with so am is
urgent pm is more strategic
and long term nice and then do you
review
what fills up that strategic time at the
end of each week monthly is that
something that you do or
um yes i do i always
do a day planning a week plan and i
always have a little time to review over
the month but
typically it would just be who are my
best candidates
and and selling them in but it's also
staying on top of can
clients that i've not spoken to for you
know a couple of months and making sure
that you're
you're having that second that third
that fourth conversation
with a customer because you're not gonna
speak to someone
and then suddenly get a load of business
you really need to invest in that
relationship it could be ten times
that you call them but each time you add
into the the picture of what they hire
and what they struggle with
so yeah no matter how busy i am it's
making time for
business development yeah amazing liz
thank you for sharing that
that was 50 minutes of a mentor thank
you
thanks for having me